في صحيفه الوس جورنال وجد تقرير ان
تحليلات الخبراء تشكك في قدره اسرائيل على
تحقيق نصر في حربها ضد حماس ضمن الجدول
الزمني الذي يسعى المسؤولون الامريكيون
لالزام به جاء في التقرير استنادا الى
مسؤولين ومحللين اسرائيليين ان القوات
الاسرائيليه مازالت تواجه مقاومه شرسه لم
تكن تتوقعها في شمال غزه ما يؤخر تحويل
تركيزها الى الجنوب في صحيفه الجارديان
حديث عن غضب دولي متزايد بين اقرب حلفاء
اسرائيل على خلفيه الارتفاع الكبير في عدد
الوفيات في غزه والماساه التي يعيشها اكثر
من مليون نازح في ظل غياب قدر كاف من
الغذاء والماء تشير الصحيفه الى تساؤلات
بشان التقارير عن وفيات بين محتجزين
فلسطينيين لدى القوات الاسرائيليه واخرى
حول قواعد الاشتباك التي يتبعها الجيش في
غزه بعد حادثه مقتل الرهائن ثلاث وفي مقال
بصحيفته ارتس يقول يوسي ميلمان محلل
الشؤون الامنيه
والاستراتيجيه ان الحادثه الذي قتل فيه
ثلاثه من الرهائن الاسرائيليين بنيران
قوات الجيش لم ياتي من عدم بل هو نتاج
ثقافه متجذرا منذ عقود لدى الجيش
الاسرائيلي تتعلق بفتح النار على
الفلسطينيين ولدى الشرطه الاسرائيليه
باطلاق النار على المواطنين العرب داخل
اسرائيل الكاتب اضاف ان جزءا من هذه
الثقافه يتمثل ايضا في التستر على
التحقيقات وفرض عقاب مخفف يرى مقال في
صحيفه لوموند ان اسرائيل تبرر باستمرار
سلوكها في غزه بالقول انها تستند الى
القوانين باعتبارها الدعامه الاخلاقيه
التي تحدد مسار صراعها لكن الواقع حسب
الصحيفه يظهر ان تطبيق القوانين التي
تتحدث عنها يقود الى اباده جمعيه في غزه
ومن الواضح يضيف المقام قال ان اسرائيل
تستخدم القانون لاضفاء الشرعيه على العنف
في غزه وجد استطلاع للراي العام الامريكي
شاركت في اجرائه صحيفه النيويورك تايمز ان
بايدن يواجه رفضا واسعا النطاق داخل
قاعدته الانتخابيه فيما يتعلق بسياسته
تجاه الحرب في غزه اظهر الاستطلاع ما قالت
الصحيفه انه انقسام بين ناخبي بايدن
المفترضين لا يترك له سوى خيارات سياسيه
قليله للمناوره ويبعث ايضا اشارات متضاربه
بشان النهج الذي يجب ان تسلكه الاداره
الامريكيه بينما تدخل الحرب شهرها
الثالث